solve the equation and find excluded
values and what they're talking about
about finding excluded values is we need
to think about what values would make
these either side of this equation
undefined and the reason why we want to
do that is because as we manipulate this
we might lose things in the denominator
and then we might get some answer but if
it's one of those things that made the
original
the original expressions or either side
of the original equation undefined then
that wouldn't be a legitimate solution
so that's what they're talking about the
excluded values so what values do we
have to exclude here right from the get
go well 4 over p minus 1 won't be
defined if p is 1 because if p is 1 then
this then you're going to be dividing by
zero and that's undefined so we know
that p cannot be equal to one
and over here if p was at negative three
then this denominator would be zero and
it would be undefined and so p cannot be
equal to one or
negative 3. so these right here are our
excluded values so now let's try to
solve let's try to solve this equation
and i'm going to rewrite it over here so
your 4 over p minus 1 is equal to 5
over p plus 3. so the first thing we can
do especially because we can assume now
that neither of these expressions are 0
and this is going to be defined since
we've excluded these values of p
is to get the p minus 1 out of the
denominator we can multiply the left
hand side by p minus 1. but remember
this is an equation if you want them to
continue to be equal anything you do to
the left hand side you have to do to the
right hand side so i'm multiplying by p
minus 1.
now i also want to get this p plus 3 out
of the denominator here on the right
hand side so the best way to do that is
multiply the right hand side by p plus
three but if i do that to the right hand
side i also have to do that to the left
hand side
p
p plus three
and so what happens we have a p minus
one in the numerator p minus 1 in the
denominator
these cancel out so you have just a 1 in
the denominator or you have no
denominator anymore and the left hand
side simplifies to 4 times p plus 3
or if you were to distribute the four
four times p plus three so that is
four p
plus twelve and then the right hand side
you have a p plus three canceling with
the p plus three this is the plus three
divided by p plus 3 and all you're left
with is 5 times p minus 1 if you
distribute the 5 you get 5 p
5 p minus 5. now this is a pretty
straightforward linear equation to solve
we just want to isolate the ps on one
side and the constants on the other so
let's subtract 5p from both sides i'll
switch colors so let's subtract 5p
from both sides
and we get
on the left hand side
4p minus 5p is negative p plus 12 is
equal to these cancel out is equal to
negative 5 and then we can subtract 12
from both sides subtract 12 from both
sides
and we get these cancel out we get
negative p is equal to negative 5 minus
12 is negative 17 and we're almost done
we can multiply both sides by negative 1
or divide both sides by negative 1
depending on how you want to view it
and we get negative 1 times negative p
is so let me just scroll down a little
bit so i have a little bit of real
estate i that's positive p is equal to
17.
p is equal to
17. and let's verify that this really
works well it wasn't one of our excluded
values but just just in case let's
verify that it really works if we go
if we have p is 17 we get 4
over 17 minus 1
needs to be equal to 5 over 17 plus 3.
i'm just putting 17 in for p because
that's our solution
so this is the same thing as 4 over
16 needs to be the same thing as 5 over
20.
or 4 16 is the same thing as 1 4 and
that needs to be the same thing as 5 20
which is the same thing as 1 4. so it
all checks out so these are excluded
values and lucky for us this wasn't one
of them